libertad de expresión y libertad para
enseñar es lo que algunos manifestantes
gritan en medio de las calles de parís
en memoria de samuel para ti un profesor
que fue asesinado cuando regresaba a
casa luego de su jornada en una escuela
de una localidad al norte de la capital
francesa algunos llevaron carteles que
decían yo soy profesor y muchos se
unieron para demostrar su apoyo y
solidaridad tenemos que unirnos estar
juntos en solidaridad y mostrar que esto
es inaceptable
es lo que sucedió es horrible y no
podemos dejarlo pasar un profesor no fue
libre para enseñar el asesino de samuel
para ti fue un joven de 18 años presunto
extremista originario de chechenia antes
de ser asesinado para ti fue objeto de
una campaña airada en las redes sociales
por mostrar imágenes de profeta mahoma
en sus clases los manifestantes también
llevaron carteles de la publicación
satírica charlie hebdo haciendo el
paralelo de los ataques ocurridos en
francia en los últimos años puedes creer
que esto está pasando desde 2012
mohamed mirad charly el teatro bataclán
y ahora los profesores
deparará esto como ella muchos ven el
asesinato de patti como otro ataque a la
república y a sus valores ellos atacaron
las instalaciones de charlie hebdo hace
unos años y ahora van tras el sistema de
educación para mí la escuela debe ser
secular y garantizar los valores de la
república francesa y de todos
un minuto de silencio y el himno
nacional un homenaje del pueblo francés
al profesor de historia asesinado por
enseñar la libertad de expresión